e
[Musique]
ce combat nous mettre au point un code
cetto voit la côte du 33 même vous
attendez deux secondes six buts lèvres
l'infraction vous restez là deux groupes
faisaient dans la facture
[Musique]
bernard
monsieur ou madame s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
à dori
ici attention nahr al-bared assiégée
dont la faction
on n'a pas besoin de regarder les
vitrines ici non parce que là ce sont
des vieilles vitrine il faut vite et
bien gardé mais là du vieux tissus et
tout ça pour donner des mauvaises idées
aux
[Musique]
fait du bien
k
[Musique]
y
êtes vous allé un peu vite regardez j'ai
vu là-bas non
vous doublez pour les accidents
monsieur regarder avec mettez votre bras
comme ça regardez
vous là ce monsieur sait qu'il c'est qui
celui là
et j'en ai justement le projet que vous
êtes passé ouais je me fais passer c'est
lui attendez le moins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comtois avec les mobiles ceux qui sont
pressés mais qui fait de présenter
deux voitures et il est jeune qu'on
lapide laissant des boulevards entier
avec une seule planche à roulettes et
vous faudra parfois
[Musique]